we are here in Pittsburgh for ubers
self-driving car launch I'm opening the
app there we go you'll see there's a
sort of pinwheel thing on top it's a
lidar sensor that's sort of the most
important sensor that is mapping the
road and and basically telling the car
where to go in all there are dozens of
these sensors 20 cameras seven lasers
radars we have these lovely safety
drivers here joining us but but the idea
is to sort of get people to understand
what it's like without somebody behind
the wheel so we're in the uber and I'm
gonna press this green button giant
green button and the iPad that says
let's ride there is sort of a weird sort
of colorful psychedelic map that's
showing all of the you know stuff going
on around as the driver is sort of
hovering with his hands over the wheel
but not not touching the wheel or just
barely touching the wheel and here we're
we're stopped at a stop sign there's
cars going by you can see them on the on
the screen I am going to take the
driver's seat and basically experience
you know what it's like to be a safety
driver
so this is eerie it really feels like
car has a mind of its own it's weird you
know you're fighting the tendency to
grab the wheel I've had my hands it's
sort of grazing the wheel and sort of
ready to go but otherwise I've done
literally nothing I'm just sort of
sitting here enjoying the ride